you can work at a pretty high intensity
with your workouts and a pretty high
intensity with your job as long as
you're getting sleep and as long as
you're eating the right types of foods
but if you're not getting the sleep
that's our master recovery area and if
you're not getting the right type of
sleep
then it doesn't matter if you're not
over training it doesn't matter if
you're not stressed at work you're going
to be in that stress state from a lack
of sleep people will be amazed if they
cut out the one hour of netflix and
chill and added that to their sleep on
how much that would make them feel
better the next day do we really have to
stop the chill i mean with the next
flicks and chill like i feel like the
chill probably has some really good
hormonal benefits yeah yeah the chill
part totally um the negative is you're
just looking at a light and it's totally
destroying your melatonin production
which is our sleep hormone and so wait i
thought that meant sex sorry
the chill part is great
chill part great let's get rid of the
netflix part just jump to the chill part
and that's perfect welcome to the pretty
intense podcast we have a pretty intense
nutritional day
with autumn bates she is a certified
clinical nutritionist she has her
masters in nutrition and human
performance i found out about her on
youtube she has an incredible
amount of content she's really clear and
concise and to the point and she talks a
ton about how to fast what to take what
to eat what not to eat how your hormones
are working things that lead to weight
gain everything in the realm of health
and what we're consuming so i was most
interested in intermittent fasting and
how that works and the effect on the
body and especially from a female
perspective we also talked about you
know the sis the body as a system as
opposed to my old
thinking of it which was multiple
systems her passion is all about the
fueling window and not necessarily so
much about the fast itself because
that's just happening but what are we
consuming during enjoy consuming all of
this info because there's a lot get a
pen and paper out because this is a
pretty intense episode what type of
pills are you taking
i started working with a functional
medicine doctor this year and um i mean
it's it's all the stuff to improve
detoxification pathways so it's like
nac nad
vitamin c
glutathione l-glutamine
i'm also like you know i'm starting
chelation
for
heavy metal poisoning so which heavy
metal were you poisoned with mercury and
blood
yeah as we say lead is the one that's
pretty common because it's yeah your
word via the placenta birth oh yeah
exactly that's what i heard is that it's
hereditary yeah yeah like the mother can
um especially if you're like your mom
grew up in the 60s um a lot of lead was
just used during that time and it just
stays in there unless you're doing
something like you're doing and it gets
passed on to the baby sometimes like
tomorrow i start another chelations like
five days on nine days off for three
months so something my in my first cycle
but before that it was all about the gut
so having i have dysbiosis and then so i
was on you know and leaky gut which is
kind of the same thing i feel like in
general it seems like
so i was on all those protocols and so i
just eat pills all day long
which is probably what makes me really
curious about all this stuff too because
when we which is especially why i've
dove into so much of your information
because having to do with like autophagy
and
you know cells kind of being able to you
know heal themselves and die off and
regenerate and do all the things it
needs to do it's like you know but yet i
feel like i'm one of those people that
just work does a lot better when i don't
have such long breaks without food and i
i get behind and it's really hard to
catch up and
so there's like so much to it but how
did you i mean like how did you get into
it i think that i've read something
about anxiety and things like that but
you know what was the impetus to send
you down this path of being able to just
you know just throw content at us like
crazy and it just clearly flows out of
you
yeah i um i mean my background's in
nutrition and so it's always just been
more focused on food like the food
aspect and the biochemistry of the body
and i
growing up have had so much issues so
many issues with bloating where it was
so severe where i after every meal i
would eat i would have to lay down on
something because it would just be so
painful that i couldn't like sit up
without feeling like i'd like unbutton
my pants or something because it was
just so expanded and i especially during
that time i feel like there's a lot of
stuff going on on social media where
it's like bloating is normal like look
i'm really bloated too and i remember
that can't be the case like the body
can't just all the time you eat be like
okay now we're gonna make you incapable
of doing anything now
um so then it this is a while ago my
dad's chiropractor and he um was
learning about fasting and
i was very scared of that concept i was
like i can't possibly go without food
like no way
when i wake up i eat every two hours
like that's what i've always been
trained to do especially in nutrition
space
uh but then eventually the bloating just
got so bad where i was like okay
and maybe there might be something that
could help with this and it was just so
miraculous on how
well it cleaned my gut how well it just
completely eliminated bloating i never
get bloated now unless i'm doing
something wrong that i know i shouldn't
be and
it makes it that i never want to go back
and i want other people to feel that way
too
yeah i i that you like totally hit it
right on the head for me it's like
people who describe me as being
disciplined and i don't really go off
too much and to me
i don't have a desire to be like a big
old cheat day where i eat a bunch of
pizza and gluten and dairy and all kinds
of stuff that i know will make me
distended or feel bad because like my
main goal is to feel good and so i can
feel good trust me i can eat plenty of
calories like i have no problem
consuming calories or eating all day
long if i need to have a you know if i
need to jolt my metabolism because i've
been you know sort of repressing it for
a while with any kind of restricted
eating um
which i don't normally do so i stay
pretty regimented but it's totally the
feeling good and what's crazy is that
people
i think there's a like there's a lot of
people that don't even know what feel
good
means
yeah and i mean my whole like slogan
with my channel is that i want you to
feel good again but also a lot of people
don't even have that again part it's
like for the first time
and that's actually been something
really cool to see with clients or just
people who are commenting on my channel
where they're like oh my gosh i didn't
realize that i didn't have to feel this
way all the time or i didn't realize how
badly i was feeling a hundred percent of
the time until i started to actually
feel good
what is the most common thing that
people um cut out that makes a big
difference
you mean in terms of like food or
fasting yeah yeah food i'd say food
off the bat
yeah um
snacking
i mean it's not it's not even a specific
food it's snacking because that's why
intermittent fasting is so great for
especially the gut healing aspect which
is what you're going to feel the most
immediately you're going to feel less
bloated you're going to not get gas and
like that distension and that's
something you feel right away and with
snacking you are breaking up the same
benefit that you would get from fasting
where you're stopping the gut cleaning
process called the migrating motor
complex if you've listened to like any
of my videos you've probably heard me
say it 20 times that like it's all the
big words i love it
it helps educate people i mean that's
how i learn i love to i love to hear
things i haven't heard before so feel
free to go as deeper as in
specific as you like
yeah um and with when you remove
snacking you actually activate that even
between meals so it takes three and a
half three hours 45 minutes like pretty
much that specific area-ish of number to
get a full cycle of the migrating motor
complex to be completed so if you were
eating like every two hours you're never
actually cleaning out your gut which
means you're always getting that
bacteria and left fine food built up in
your small intestine and so any other
food that's coming through is just
getting fermented and that fermentation
is creating gas and that's when you get
that bloating distension acid reflux
a lot of women and men as well are
getting small intestine bacterial
overgrowth or sibo so all of that what
i've seen is one of the biggest things
that people can make an immediate
improvement on even if they aren't using
fasting is just simply cutting out
snacking not even changing their diet at
first but removing the snacks can help
massively to stimulate that mmc and to
be clear snacking is
anything like i mean i'm thinking like
you know oh so what if i have a coffee
with something in it what if i have
um like be clear like fast or snacking
is anything yeah anything other than
water so if you have um i mean there's
some debate and it can depend on each
person because technically speaking
stress can slow down the mmc as well so
you know some people get a stress
response in response to caffeine so even
though you know black coffee doesn't
contain technically any food or calories
that should disrupt mnc if you get a
stress response from it it can slow it
down
um so that's where if you really want to
maximize gut health having just water in
between your meals will make it so that
the mmc can stay stimulated
wow i i have tried some of that and i i
mean like more intermittent fasting and
more like less snacking i i wore a um
blood glucose monitor a continuous blood
glucose monitor for a couple months
that is an education have you ever done
that
i have one i still haven't done it but
yeah i need to try it out i have a
glucose meter and a ketone meter but
a continuous glucose monitor one
yeah and and it's amazing how certain
foods will you know spike your insulin
and then just anything i mean any food
whatsoever you think like even you think
like oh i just had some protein like
protein does it too you know maybe not
as not as bad as a sweet potato but
right you know it it still does it so i
feel like that's kind of my first the
first phase of education i got which is
like digital proof right you're looking
at your own shoot
um
and um so so getting into the meat of
fasting and i have so many questions
because being a girl i just feel like
things must be different i mean like
what was your journey through the
testing of it all because i'm you seem
like the kind of person that has tried
it all on yourself yeah i did i started
off with the 16 hour which i don't
really recommend doing i recommend now
starting off with like a 12 hour just
because that's a really great way to
ease into the process so that you aren't
shocking your system and you're able to
more strategically plan out your meals
you can actually get enough of your
nutrient needs during the fast or during
the eating window rather um that's a big
problem with women that i've seen is
that they don't get enough during their
eating window and that's what makes it
unsustainable for them to continue on
with intermittent fasting and why they
get so hungry
but we can get into that in a bit but
yeah i did the 16 hour fast first and
then i was like oh my gosh i feel
amazing if i feel great with 16 hours
probably like i'll feel even better with
20 hours or like a 24 hour fast so i
tried all those
and i made the mistakes that i now warn
people against where i didn't get enough
food for my body system because it's
really hard especially with protein to
get all those needs in during such a
short window and especially if you're
fasting for a full day you can't really
make up your protein needs from that day
with alternate day fasting for example
so whenever you see like studies that
are um talking about intermittent
fasting not being great for women
they're always talking about alternate
day fasting or extended fasting they're
never talking about time restricted
feeding and if they are it's when you're
not getting enough food for your body
where you're constantly in a calorie
restricted state which just in general
calorie restriction is horrible for
women it's already been found to cause a
lot of fertility issues with women long
term hormones it's hard on your hormones
right and so just to be clear though
alternate day fasting does that mean 12
16 12 16 or does that mean
24 and then you eat all day the next day
yeah it literally means one day fast one
day you don't so 24 hours yeah you fast
for 24 hours and then the next day you
don't fast you can eat like what's
called a quote unquote normal day where
you wake up and eat right away i have a
lot of problems with the alternate day
fasting i know there's been some people
have seen success with it but not only
do you not get enough of your needs but
it's so not sustainable for life like
how do you plan out your life to be like
okay on this day i'm not going to fast
on that day and but it's it's john's
birthday on that day and i know we're
going to be going out to eat so am i
just going to like have sparkling water
like it doesn't make sense logistically
long term and i think that especially in
the intermittent fasting space it's so
filled with these like highly
overachieving people where they have the
ability and the discipline to like
schedule their life to an alternate day
fast vertical nine out of ten people
probably more than that can't do that or
don't want to do that and if we're only
preaching those methods then we're not
going to actually help everyone else
where you they could get so many results
with time-restricted feeding yeah so you
found that 16 was the best what did you
find with 18 and maybe you tried 18
maybe just went to 20. and then did you
ever do omad as well one meal a day
i did try out omad so that's like a 22
hour fast essentially
um i also i again i have clients who
that works for them um i found most
people it doesn't because like let's
just say your protein needs like mine
are about 80 or 90 grams per day have
you ever tried to sit down and eat that
much protein at one meal it's not
clearly nearly impossible especially
from a complete protein source
i mean you're it's really hard to
actually get everything that your body
needs with a one meal day it can be done
some people do it well but um i found
for myself at most i can do two meal a
day which you know will be about a six
hour eating window um so like an 18 hour
fast but i also find success with the 12
or even 14 hour there were some recent
studies that showed um even if you could
just do 12-hour fasting per day you get
a lot of the same benefits as a 16 or an
18-hour fast really so what's happening
what's the science to why
we should be doing it i mean obviously
there's some gut help and we heard a
little bit about you know bloating and
that kind of stuff and letting the the
um the what's the mm what's the word
again yeah we can we could just leave it
to mmc it's migrating
but mmc is the easy term
there i mean it all comes down to if we
can understand the basic idea of what
our bodies need to do every day we need
to build up and we need to break down we
can't always be building we can't always
be breaking down so even if you look at
like with strength training with
workouts something that all of us are a
little bit more familiar with we know
that we need to work out which is
breaking down but then we also need rest
and that rest is where the muscle builds
back up
so it's the same thing with literally
everything else in our body we need to
have those ups and downs we need for our
gut we need to be breaking down food so
we can get the nutrients we need but our
gut is also a machine so it needs rest
in order to have the you know the
cleaning crew come in to clean up what
was left behind um so that it can do its
job efficiently the next day same thing
with our cells like what you're talking
about autophagy or mitochondria there's
a lot of different
like more specific biology terms there
um but basically your cells need to you
know they're always recreating itself um
each cell has a different lifespan but
we need to actually be able to break
down cells in order to create new cells
that are healthy again and that's with
fasting what you're doing we're always
in this state of perpetual building up
if you're eating all day long you're
always building you're always um trying
to break down food so that you can have
that anabolic or build up state but you
never actually get into that cleanup
crew time and with yourselves with your
gut that's what you're really focused on
in terms of fasting each day
wow yeah i mean super powerful stuff
especially for how much stuff we deal
with now and
dealing with the environment and getting
sick and you know just like just i mean
i wonder too is that is this linked to
aging even i mean is there a link to a
lack of
cell cleanup to the aging process
yeah i mean
it's kind of hard to specifically track
down what's linked to aging just because
there's so many factors you can't really
isolate one thing down but it would make
sense if you think of just from a
logistical thought process where uh like
if you think of the analogy of having a
car if you're always driving you never
get it tuned up then it's going to break
down faster than if you allowed to get
tuned up so yeah i mean i would theorize
but there's no way to really test that
yeah i know a lot about cars so that's
true yeah
you need a pit crew doing you know
diving into this and learning more and
learning more about the timing and of
course your sleep does count as fasting
but what is happening when you aren't
sleeping and you're fasting like today i
was i feel like
i feel like a damn hero i stopped eating
at eight o'clock last night and i got up
and i
had a little black coffee i always drink
black coffee and i went to the gym and
worked out for an hour
i had to pick my car up i picked my car
up i came home and then i still was
going i'm like okay and so i went and
did my red light for 20 minutes and then
i sat in the sauna for 25 minutes and i
got right and then i went and finally
ate and by the way i was starving but it
was probably i think i ate it somewhere
almost noon like 11 30 or 12 o'clock so
for me that's like a really long window
so what's happening during the awake
hours versus the sleep hours are they
the same are they different
it's
i mean from a cellular perspective like
autophagy it's pretty similar because a
lot of it's dictated by insulin so when
you're insulin our storing hormone is
high which it is when we're when we've
eaten um then that whole autophagy
sequence is turned off but when it's low
because we're fasting autophagy is
turned on for so from a cellular
perspective it's pretty much the same
regardless of if you're asleep or awake
but the migrating motor complex is a
little different where when you're
asleep it's not fully activated you know
it slows down quite a bit so you you
don't get the full
that three hour 45 minute window of how
long it takes with your cycle is
extended so you want to make sure you
have the waking hours of fast from a gut
healing perspective as well so you can
get that full migrating motor complex
system activated
what's happening when you do actual
activities like
walking which we will totally talk about
walking when we get more into like
fitness stuff but um you know from a
from an active
activity standpoint are there extra
benefits or things that you could
take advantage of yeah i mean during a
fasted state the huge benefit especially
with exercise is that your growth
hormone is elevated so when your growth
hormone is elevated it's more muscle
protective but it also allows you to use
fat as fuel more easily so obviously
when you're fasted i mentioned insulin
that other hormone insulin is low which
means our fat burning is cranked up so
you more efficiently especially weight
loss with your goal you're more
efficiently using fat as fuel so you're
actually tapping into fat rather than
just general weight and losing muscle
mass and you're protecting your muscle
during that state because you have that
increased growth hormone that's
protecting your muscle um during acid
state
oh wow
good so work out first is there a
certain kind of workout that's better is
it better to do sort of low intensity
stuff like walking is it
is it better to do weight lifting at
that point in time is there anything
that like ranks higher
uh so it depends on what state you're at
where you're at in your intermittent
fasting journey specifically if you're
new and if you are
still getting hungry during the fasted
state then you likely haven't really
gotten great at burning fat as fuel yet
so you need to focus on the
energy systems or the workouts that
don't require
you know using carbohydrates as a fuel
source you want to use the one you want
to do the types of workouts that are
lower intensity that don't raise the
heart rate too high so that you can
really push your body into a fat burning
state otherwise if you do like a high
intensity workout and you're already
still getting hungry during your fast
you're forcing your body to then use
carbohydrates as fuel and now you're in
that up and down cycle of
getting cravings because you you've um
broken out of that fat burning state and
now you're in a carbohydrate burning
state which is less sustainable
so you're saying i might not be in a fat
burning stem i might not be burning fat
for fuel i might be using sugar
bigger burner versus fat burner right
isn't that kind of yeah it could be that
or it could be what you're eating during
your eating window which a lot of people
forget about and that's something huge
if you've seen my channel like one video
that you probably noticed i really focus
on is the actual eating window portion
because the fast is great that's really
important that's where you're actually
getting a lot of the benefits but you
can ruin it during the eating window and
that is something that
no one talks about and it's so
unfortunate because that's the area
where i made the huge mistakes because i
was not doing it right now i was doing
awful and i wasn't getting the benefits
that everyone was talking about what
does awful mean like hungry all the time
like what does awful mean in your eating
window oh okay um yeah back then i
definitely was not eating enough protein
that was the biggest one um and i was
eating a lot more of simple
carbohydrates that were you know when
you're in a fast you're using fat but
then if you go immediately to using
carbohydrates as a fuel source it kind
of confuses the body and it gets you to
more of an up and down energy cycle
during your eating window so it's harder
to transition back into a fat burning
state once you go into the fast
and that's the mistake i made
got it so by simple carbohydrates are
you talking like white bread kind of
like simple carbohydrates are you
talking about like simple meaning like
sweet potato like is that more simple or
rice
yeah um i was having much more fruit in
my smoothies so i love smoothies and i
was dumping fruit in like had so much i
would even put like honey in like just
simple sugars um things that we think of
as healthy and they get like a health
halo but it's a lot of sugar and it will
switch your body into using sugar as a
fuel source instead of using fat so that
was one big thing was fact that was
breaking my fast with a really high
sugar smoothie um and then
also still snacking i wasn't eating
until satiated at each of my meals i was
even snacking within my eating window
and that made it so i was never fully
satisfied and so i was going into my
fast already hungry
ah yeah i think i've totally made the
mistake of not eating enough in the
window like which is why i like get
behind because i don't eat enough in
that window to feel good for a long time
so let's talk about insulin and maybe
start off with first insulin with the
workout because i do get confused with
the insulin because my insulin did spike
with workout and so you know let's talk
about that and then we'll talk about
insulin with a food since we're talking
about you know for you know movement
then we'll talk about food it was
probably your blood glucose that spike
because it's pretty hard to track
insulin especially oh yeah blood glucose
yeah sorry yeah so i'm assuming you're
probably doing a higher intensity
exercise usually yeah
i take it from the podcasting yeah
yeah uh higher intensity exercise is
just like what i was referring to with
sticking to lower intensity exercises
that use fat as fuel higher intensity
requires carbohydrates you know when you
get to a certain level in your heart
rate your body can't use fat because
there's just not enough oxygen available
because you're um you're just you're
breathing too hard you your intensity is
too high that you now need to be
switching into a faster energy source
which is carbohydrates and with our um
stored carbohydrates that's in our
muscle in our muscle glycogen that's
when our body will spike our stress
hormone cortisol in order to release it
and that's why with the higher intensity
exercise you see a spike in blood
glucose because it's releasing all that
glucose from your muscles in order to
fuel that higher intensity exercise so
it's not necessarily um insulin i mean
insulin will definitely rise after the
fact to help bring that down if it
wasn't used but insulin is one that's
kind of a misunderstood hormone because
most people aren't actually measuring it
they're measuring glucose they're
measuring a1c so all like derivatives of
glucose which is important it is useful
but it's not really the big picture and
it doesn't actually show you how insulin
is working how is insulin working
so insulin is largely supposed to only
be released from our body when we've
eaten something and specifically eaten
carbohydrates um it will get released in
response to protein a little bit but not
very much and then to fats it's pretty
much zero that's why like if you hear
people who are following the keto diet
they keep their insulin really low even
though they're eating all day um even if
they aren't using fasting because
they're eating primarily fat so insulin
isn't really released so insulin um i
mean you've probably heard most people
they've heard of insulin they've heard
it in relation to type 2 diabetes or
type 1 diabetes we just think of it as
like that area but about a cdc just came
out with a report i think is in 2017
about 100 million americans have an
issue with higher insulin levels which
is like one-third of people
and that's really the hormone that will
regulate if we're using fat or
carbohydrates so even just from the
perspective of weight loss
you want to be looking after your
insulin and you want to be controlling
for that and not overly spiking it um
and then also with fasting that's where
that hurt comes in when you're in a
fasted state because insulin you're not
eating you're so stepped down and the
body shifts into that fat burning state
like what leads to weight gain because
maybe we should talk about calories
first yeah
the
the the myth of calories and
when you actually think about it like
think about calories and like how do
they even measure it getting really
sciencey they use um what's called
called a bomb caliber calorimeter uh i
think that's how you pronounce it that's
like not interesting at all they're just
basically measuring how much heat is
expelled but in terms of calories and
why we should even care about them it is
one of the most hotly debated topics
within nutrition there's two big camps
one says it's only calories it doesn't
matter where they come from it's
calories in calories out the other is
looking at it from a hormonal
perspective which is what nutrition is
shifting toward you know
just calories and calories out is really
old school mentality unfortunately it's
just still the only prevailing thing
taught in schools
like i had my undergrad and master's and
ccn programs and they're all just still
talking just about calories and not the
hormonal effect
there's a big disconnect when you go
from like physiology class where they're
talking about insulin and how it shuts
off fat burning and turns on um and
turns on fat storage instead and then
you go into nutrition class and they're
like it's only calories in calories out
but i know that's a little aside um in
terms of calories it's really just an
energy unit it doesn't really say much
about where it's going to be stored or
how it's going to be used so like
protein for example we don't really use
for energy we use it to build we use it
to create new cells we use it to create
hormones to create the lining of our gut
it's not something unless we're in a
starved state that we're using as an
energy source um and then if you look at
carbohydrates carbohydrates and fat
those two are are our energy sources so
those are the two that we actually like
if you're
lifting weight you're using
carbohydrates you're using fat you're
not going to be using protein really
yeah so you can just kind of think of it
as like a switch you're either using the
carbohydrates or you're using the fat
when you're using energy protein is
water burner fat burner exactly yeah
exactly
so that's where you get the whole um
debate on how much of an impact hormones
actually have versus just simply
calories there's a lot of studies that
are now showing that looking at it from
a hormonal perspective
has a bigger impact on weight loss
versus just calories and calories out i
mean you could look at
the biggest loser study where the show
the biggest loser where people were
eating like 800 calories a day and um
having that over an extended time and
their metabolism is wrecked as a result
and they can't lose weight after that
and now they're obese again even eating
800 calories a day so clearly that
method and that model doesn't work and
there's studies now showing that based
off of the types of foods you're eating
you can actually dictate if you're going
to be burning fat and maintaining muscle
mass or if you're just you know going to
decrease your metabolism
explain more about that
so
her body um
it's always trying to preserve itself so
it's always trying to make sure that we
have enough to
run the basic functions that's its first
core thing it's focused on it's focused
on being able to create new hormones and
have
our brain cells functioning have our
heart beat and so protein helps to
maintain all of that in terms of
building but then when it comes to um
you know calorie intake once you start
to decrease your energy intake you start
to shut off what's available for your
body to use to fuel its essential
systems so that's why when people start
to decrease like let's say they usually
eat 2 000 calories a day and they drop
it down to 1500 calories a day to try
and lose like one pound a week type of
thing
now they have less energy for their body
to actually use to fuel their brain to
fuel their heart and so in order to
protect those essential systems the body
will decrease the energy used for other
areas that are less essential so that's
where you'll see
women losing their period or and having
fertility issues because why some blood
flow there it's not essential right now
when we need to be able to breathe and
have our heartbeat and have our brain
think um you'll see hair loss because
you're not getting enough to actually
produce hair
um so that's just you know the calorie
perspective
from the hormone hormonal perspective it
tells you where that energy is used
rather than i'm just simply reducing it
so if you're looking from for weight
loss you're trying to lose weight but
you want to maintain all these systems
and you want to burn fat not just
overall weight you want to tell you want
your hormones to dictate where that
energy is going you want it to um you
want to tell your body to pull energy
from your fat not from your muscles and
you want your body to then have enough
energy for your brain your heart but
also your hair so that's where the
hormones can start to if you can master
what types of foods
you're going to be eating that then
dictate where those things are being
partitioned with insulin being that key
one of regulating burning fat or
carbohydrates then you can avoid a lot
of those issues of decreased metabolism
and fertility issues
okay so outline in a good and a bad
scenario using your hormones to
direct what happens in the body versus a
bad scenario and like what you would
consume and i know everybody's a little
bit different but there's probably some
generalities there what does that look
like and what hormones are we talking
about
yeah well the key hormone is going to be
insulin it's one that's the master
hormone that will dictate especially
from a weight loss perspective
everything that's going on um i mean
insulin can affect other hormones
downstream as well so
it's kind of like the one that we have
the most control over immediately and
that can also um directly affect weight
loss as a result so if we're talking
about like the alternative where you
know it's just simply
decreasing calories it could be anything
you could be having cookies all day and
have 1500 calories worth of cookies but
you're gonna quote calorie deficient
state uh that's where even though you're
eating 1500 calories you're eating a lot
of refined sugars and carbohydrates
that's like insulin so you could be
eating less quote-unquote energy than
what your body needs but that energy is
being told to be stored
and it's not being told to be used
does that make sense yeah yeah so let's
replace it like let's replace it with
you know as you talk about so much like
fat protein and fiber so let's replace
that idea with a like 1500 calories of
that then what happens yeah so when you
have let's do that same example 1500
calories and you have um 20 of that
coming from protein now your protein
needs are covered your body doesn't
think it's in a state of starvation so
that's the number one macronutrient that
will dictate if your body thinks it's in
the state of starvation or not really
yeah there's studies also done on high
protein versus low protein diets but
with the same amount of calorie intake
of like 800 calories a day and those who
are on the higher protein quote higher
but it's like 20
higher protein diets don't have the
starvation issues and don't have the
decreased metabolism that the low
protein diet has
so that's where we can avoid that why
why protein is the first component of
the protein fat and fiber making sure
you actually get enough protein for your
needs and most people aren't most people
have no idea how much protein they need
or they think that they're getting
plenty
that's a big myth in the nutrition world
and then the fat component makes it so
you're providing your body energy and
satiety so this is where we get into
another hormone um cholecystokinin which
is our satiety hormone tells our brain
that we're full we're satisfied we don't
need to eat so it helps us regulate our
appetite actually so that we don't need
to be eating beyond what we really need
we can self-regulate without having to
have a calorie tracker by eating enough
of both protein and fat both of those
release satiety hormones that tell our
brain we're full and that we don't need
to keep eating the problem comes in when
you add highly insulin spiking foods
that
kind of
get bypass that whole system and make it
so that you spike your hunger again so
if you have enough of the fat component
to actually get satisfied and to tell
your brain that you're full and you
don't need to keep eating you not only
have an energy source but you can also
indiscriminately pull from your own
energy source from your own fat source
as well because your body doesn't
discriminate between the fat you're
eating or the fat that's in your body so
it will pull back and forth between the
fat that you're eating and the fat
that's in your body which is why people
who focus on protein fat and fiber will
get a decrease
body fat percentage while still
maintaining muscle mass which is
normally unheard of which is a calorie
restrictive state it's always like a
bulking season i'm going to increase
muscle mass but inevitably fat will go
up and then i'm going to get cutting
season and decrease both
yeah totally so how much what is the
guideline for protein like what is the
recommended yeah the recommended like if
you look at usda guidelines it's really
just recommended so that you don't
starve like that's what it's recommended
at usda let's not use usda exactly i
mean from my understanding the food
pyramid and all of that crap is made by
the people that sell you all their
ingredients let's not use anything that
the government has
let's go off of autumn's experience and
all of your
your your education and what you see in
the real world and what you see for
yourself what is the what is a great
guideline for the amount of protein the
formula that i use is a range so it's
1.2 to 1.6 grams of protein per kilogram
of body weight so what number what about
pounds i know it's so annoying it's okay
so you just take your weight divide by
two point two there's skills okay so
it's pretty easy but um the reason why
there's a little bit of a range for that
just depends on how much stress your
body is under because when you're under
more stress you need more protein
because your body when it's under state
of stress it's breaking down so you need
that protein to help build back up so a
stress could be exercise like if you're
exercising a lot then you'd be on the
range of 1.6 grams of protein per
kilogram of body weight if you're under
fairly low stress and you're just
walking which is great exercise but it's
not a highly stressful exercise you
could probably be fine with 1.2 grams
per kilogram of body weight but that's
the range that i like to use and i
always suggest like i have a couple
different videos on that to walk through
um but that's a good range to cover your
needs so that you aren't going to be
under consuming well let's just talk
about vegans then i'm vegetarians um
i'm i'm gonna guess that you don't
condone that like you or like you
wouldn't say that that's your chosen
path
yeah i mean i work with everyone on
whatever it is that they i'm because i
know ethically there's reasons why
people would want to begins um i tried
for a little while too and i'm like
that's probably what left me in a
extremely
uh
and i use extremely without using it
five times which i should high level of
mercury because i then was like well
maybe like fish is okay and i'm sure
that was part of the equation but um but
yeah i mean i tried too and i i never
felt that great right yeah i was a
vegetarian for um the first like 10
years of my life and then i tried vegan
for like a year in college
as a lot of people do
uh but yeah it's it is more difficult to
get complete protein it's not impossible
but it is more difficult and the
complete protein is what people forget
like if they're just tracking their
calories they're like oh i i got 100
grams of protein i'm fine but it's
counting protein from broccoli it's
counting protein from peanut butter it's
counting protein from all these other
sources that aren't complete proteins
where you're actually deficient in
complete protein because you actually
didn't account for that and in order to
be complete obviously you need all of
the essential amino acids but
specifically you need one called leucine
so leucine is the main amino acid i mean
you probably heard it through all of
your trainings but it's the one that we
need in order to stimulate muscle
synthesis or muscle growth so if we
don't have that then we aren't actually
making proteins efficiently and um you
know with a lot of the
plant-based proteins
they're usually not going to be complete
and if they are they're going to be low
leucine like uh tofu or soy proteins
there's a another study um in the sports
nutrition world where it compared soy
protein versus i believe it was whey
protein and it found that um soy was 85
lower in leucine so 85 less effective in
fact um the soy protein did just as well
as the control that didn't have any
protein in terms of muscle growth
so it is definitely more difficult it
can't it's not that can't be done but
you'll likely need to take brain chain
amino acids um and to help get that back
up
uh vegetarian it's easier it's actually
not too hard because eggs and
dairy-based proteins are some of the
best proteins you can be getting there
are some of the richest in leucine so
you can totally be a vegetarian and have
no issues have to take no supplements
and then obviously if you're omnivorous
it's the easiest way because just
getting all of your different variety
proteins from
animal-based products is most rich in
leucine yeah and then there's you know
as i've learned like bioavailability of
of of the
what you're eating and um so i'm kind of
curious of like your hierarchy of
bioavailability um when it comes to
protein but let's start with protein
powder because i always have such a
question with this i'm like does it
really count is it the same thing and
you know then my mind's like well it's
kind of like kind of going the sweet i
always think of food in a sweet savory
sort of way i'm like i'm like oh and i'm
trying to do i'm trying to follow for a
while it's been like i don't know almost
two weeks trying to do tim ferriss's
like slow carb diet with like basically
like protein beans fat it's pretty much
that and you know greens and tons of
greens so it's very and then you have
one day off a week where you you're
supposed to go wild which is a new
concept
because your metabolism gets a little
slowed with this
your thyroid can reduce its function
there's actually never been a study
proving that that's another really big
myth that thyroid yeah that lower
carbohydrate has an issue with thyroid
it i don't know where that came from
honestly that's something that i've
never actually seen the study to back
that up but it's something that it seems
as if it's been repeated so many times
that people just assume that's the case
but every study that's looking at people
who are following a higher fat lower
carbohydrate diet has no issues with
thyroid could it be caloric like a too
low calorie yeah calories reduce their
thyroid function that definitely is the
case but that's not talking about food
quality it's talking about quantity and
that could be from anything so
yeah
just to make it accessible for people
because that way people are like oh man
i mean i had like black beans and
chicken and avocado today i'm so proud
that sunday is gonna be the day
yeah
but the but from protein sources i get i
i just i in my mind i think to myself if
i'm going to if i'm gonna eat protein i
really should be eating like you know
grass-fed grass finished beef you know
free-range chicken you know trying to
eat the highest quality protein sources
i can wild fish
but but is there i mean is there is
there a general bioavailability
to protein powders that we know of or is
it such a big range because you were
talking about soy versus whey which you
know yeah um i mean there's actually a
lot of research on that just because the
sports nutrition supplement world is you
know so huge that they've done so much
research on that specific question um
but yeah depending on the type of
protein powder you're using it's
actually pretty bio-available because
it's so rich in leucine if you're using
egg or dairy-based protein
you're great but you're getting a really
high quality protein source if you're
using depending on the plant-based
source it'll range but you probably want
to increase the branch chain amino acids
if taking that
but in terms of
the actual protein it's pretty similar
but you just get other benefits from
other types of foods so like with
grass-fed grass-finished beef you get
selenium which selenium helps with the
detox pathways like what you're
referring to
i have a couple of those macadamia nuts
a day
yeah exactly um
and you get omega-3 fatty acids which
also of course is helping with
anti-inflammatory pathways too so
there's other reasons why you would want
to have more complete
complete meaning like it has all these
other nutrients or dairy where grass-fed
dairy has vitamin k2 which is so under
talked about and so under consumed um
but that's a little bit of a side
tangent but as long as you yeah
vitamin d because i take vitamin d plus
k2 is that where the k2 comes in with
the vitamin d that i need i take yeah
it's really good that you're doing that
a lot of people are just taking vitamin
d and you know for a long time we're
like i'll just load up with vitamin d
and more better
but
increasing vitamin d without taking
vitamin k2 will actually increase your
deficiency of vitamin k2 and vitamin k2
specifically needed to take calcium out
of the arteries and put it into the
bones so it actually could increase your
heart disease risk by taking vitamin d
without taking vitamin k2 or if you take
calcium supplements and you're not
taking vitamin k2 that will that's
there's a a lot of research showing that
women were getting increased heart
disease risk from taking calcium because
it wasn't actually leaving their
arteries and going into their bones but
once you add in k2
it helps to get it in there
wow i mean speaking of supplements i
mean are there some that i this is my
theory it's just that like the the food
industry it's in it's about mass
production the value of the soil i mean
we can look at the the alarming you know
potential of having only maybe 60
harvests left in our soil
um which is just a frightening thought
unless we do regenerative farming and
start you know replenish the nutrients
in the soil um
so
what are their things so my theory is is
that it's just not the same
in same nutrition in food and i've heard
the saying like you're not you're not
hungry for food you're hungry for
nutrition you know you're hungry for the
vitamins and nutrients that are within
the ingredients so i just think there's
probably some supplements that generally
speaking we just
you know we just probably need more of
because of this day and age that we live
in
i mean it's never decreased um the hard
thing to know is even what's optimal so
that's another
question where no one really knows like
what's the optimal amount of vitamin d
or magnesium or anything for each person
it's going to range like a great
question who came up with the ranking of
what's good like
i mean
damn them we're out there
they're out um of course my functional
doctor you know be like okay well you're
low in vitamin d so you know we take
this vitamin d plus k2 now it's in an
ideal spot it's not even just within the
range it's optimal you know that's what
we're shooting
that's what i get very nervous about
with supplements i rarely recommend
supplements unless it's for a very
specific reason just because it's
chemistry it's biochemistry we have no
idea how that's going to interact within
our body especially taking them all
together
i mean
just like the d3 example we thought d3
that was going to save everyone's lives
get rid of cancer by taking d3 and then
all of a sudden it increased heart
disease risk like there's no way to
really know because our body is so
complex there's so many chemical
reactions happening within it i
typically like to just get it from food
even though it might be less you know
you're not at least getting it out of
proportion in a way that was unnatural
for us to be getting it so that's you
know the proportions can also be what
really matters like we know that taking
too much omega-6 increases inflammation
in the body from all the seed oils so if
you're getting like the grass-fed beef
you're getting vitamin k2 you're getting
selenium you're getting all these things
you're getting calcium all these things
that are supposed to be packaged
together and used in that way and that's
just in my mind a safer way to go about
it rather than having
all of these supplements where we don't
really know what's happening like yeah
it might look good on a chart but what
does it really say when we discover that
there's another type of reading that we
need to be assessing in the future
so you think that the food that we can
buy
the highest quality food that we can buy
in the store um will give us all the
nutrients that we need
from
what i've seen for the vast majority of
people if you can get high quality food
sources then yeah i mean
especially with a lot of the like
multivitamins that you're not really
getting much of any of the nutrients
from that anyway
um
but there is a case we made for certain
people certain supplements like
magnesium is one that if i do recommend
that is a great one because that is
going to be a mineral that tends to be
really depleted
the issue can come in with like the
vitamins because vitamins are something
that we tend to hold on to or they tend
to even act as hormones in the body
minerals are ones that we can usually
release a little bit easier if we have
excess amounts like sodium for example
if we have high amounts of sodium we can
release it assuming that um our insulin
level isn't high
uh but yeah it's the vitamins that can
be a little bit more of a concern over
the minerals yeah i like that idea i
love the idea that i don't have to eat a
whole bunch of pills
oh my god which i have been all day
this feels like all year
i've been eating eating pills we're
talking about how a lot of times you
know certain things like food can
obviously do certain things within the
body but then there's of course fitness
and then there's like what you do um
workout wise i mean see i used to think
of the body as being like
having multiple systems i'm like oh i go
do upper body workout my lower body's
not sore i'll kill that today and then
i'll go do and then i'll go crush it and
have do a bunch of interviews and crank
my brain and really think and be focused
and so i used to think of my body as
having these multiple systems and i
could just rotate through tapping them
and kind of as time has gone and i've
gone through my health
you know struggles and journey and you
know i feel good so it's not like i
there's a lot of people in a worse
position than i am but i want optimal
and um
and i've ended up realizing wow the
whole body is like one motherboard
system and i learned a lot of this
through training for the boston marathon
this year um which was brutal in arizona
um
especially when you have to run in the
summer yeah i think the la marathon when
i lived in arizona as well
oh gosh brutal brutal i'm so sorry i
had all the empathy you could possibly
need right here
um but i i ended up starting to realize
how you know just heat in and of itself
is an element and then you know the the
the volume of the running versus the
resting and you could see how your heart
rate variability changes you can see how
your recovery changes and you could just
see and especially my functional doctors
like you want to heal all these things
but you're running a marathon like
you're really being hard on your body so
you know maybe we could talk just help
us understand you know
what what happens to the body when we
over train because i'm i'm i'm i'm
totally guilty of that yeah
i mean sounds like there
may have been overtraining but sounds
like you had over life training
going on at the same time so it's hard
to say if you were over training or if
you just had other stressors that were
making the over training more evident
so what are those stressors because
that's the thing is that they all matter
like they all are part of the same
system and i think in functional
medicine that's what i've ended up
realizing is like there's an overlap of
like everything kind of works together
and it's like one's down the other's off
and it's like it's just really really
delicate balance and um and so maybe
explaining just kind of what are the
what are all of the draining buckets
because i think there's somebody that
goes to work and they're you know
working their butt off all day and then
they come home and they have stress and
they're trying to get their work out and
they're doing this and it's like they
can't figure out why they can't lose
weight
yeah
it goes back to
the main overarching thing we talked
about intermittent fasting on how your
body needs that build up and needs the
breakdown like you can't have one or the
other and if you are um getting the tear
down of the stressors happening non-stop
where you're tearing down your muscles
so you don't actually um have any type
of recovery from your muscles but then
you also are getting a lot of mental
stress which acts physically within our
body the mental stress causes the same
type of stressors to be signaled within
our body so our body perceives it still
as a stress especially if you're um you
know operating at a higher level and
have a lot of stress with your job but
then also if you're not getting great
sleep that's other that's a huge factor
that's usually the biggest one where you
can work at a pretty high intensity with
your workouts and a pretty high
intensity with your job as long as
you're getting sleep and as long as
you're eating the right types of foods
but if you're not getting the sleep
that's our master recovery area and if
you're not getting the right type of
sleep
then it doesn't matter if you're not
over training it doesn't matter if
you're not stressed at work you're going
to be in that stress state from a lack
of sleep
so i don't know if
from your perspective it seemed like
maybe the sleep resonated a little with
you
um
actually i sleep really well
i actually sleep just fine i'm like i
tap the buckets like i'm one of those
people that's just like just
i am all about it and if i'm bored i
just go work out
yeah yeah yeah then you probably just
were overdoing it with both because
there's most people i mean you're a
little bit of a different case where you
probably just were really actually
pushing yourself to the extremes on both
work and
your exercise routine
but a lot of people don't consider sleep
so probably a lot of your listeners
don't actually get the sleep they need
to recover from those workouts or to
recover from the stress of work and
people will be amazed if they cut out
the one hour of netflix and chill and
added that to their sleep on how much
that would make them feel better the
next day i mean poor sleep increases
your stress hormone increases your
hunger hormone ghrelin the next day it
increases insulin resistance which makes
it harder to actually tap into fat
burning um so there's a lot of negative
things that happen when you sleep that
make it so that you also can't recover
because if you have a higher cortisol
higher stress level state your body
isn't in that rest and repair mode it's
in that fight-or-flight mode so you're
always going to be in that rest repair
never in or always in that fight or
flight never in that rest of repair to
recover from the stressors of the day
do we really have to stop the chill i
mean with the next flicks and chill like
i feel like the chill probably has some
really good hormonal benefits yeah yeah
the chill part totally um the negative
is you're just looking at a light and
it's totally destroying your melatonin
production which is our sleep hormone
and so wait i thought that meant sex
sorry
let's get rid of the netflix part just
jump to the chill part and that's
perfect what are the benefits of the
chill part i mean are there like is
there what are the sexual like with sex
what hormones are triggered and is it
good to do it before you go to bed i
mean does it help you sleep or what what
are the honestly that's not my area of
expertise
um if we could talk about food and
hormones all day long uh i think it
depends on the individual and if it
hypes them up or not but you know it
seems like a great option chill do it
just not too much netflix got it not too
much netflix don't know that part have
the chill part
um well one topic that i think i you
know
is i feel like is so beneficial and i
was reminded
recently going to new york and walking
like 12 miles one day and that's all i
did that day like we just went there and
we just walked around the park
and went shopping and it was just like
the mother of all walking days and i
just forget how like good you feel and
it's one of those things that you can do
and do and do and the body tolerates it
so well and even from an experiential
standpoint when i wore the continued
blood blood gluco us blood glucose
monitor is that um when i'd start
walking
my blood sugar would drop
yeah um it goes down to the couple
factors so obviously it's lower
intensity so you're not using the
glucose as a fuel source you're
switching into using fat as fuel so when
your heart rate's lower which it is when
you're walking you're using fat
primarily and that is such a sustainable
energy source we have so much fat to tap
into even if you're extremely lean even
if you have 10 body fat or lower you
have so much fat that you can use versus
two hours worth of carbohydrates that
you can use that are stored in your body
so um just by switching over to that
that's really great from that
perspective but also hormonally i mean
you said you're walking around the park
you're walking outside and walking
outside specifically you know exposes us
to something called negative ions which
has been found to decrease our serum
cortisol levels which are stress hormone
and remember cortisol raises blood
glucose so if we can decrease cortisol
we decrease stress but we also decrease
the blood glucose level as well
wow so what i mean
explain more of the science of it
because like if you're
you know what does it do what is it
doing to you when you take a walk versus
when you go into the gym and hit the
weights well first of all when you take
a walk you can do it more frequently
like you can get up i have a fitbit i
get up every hour when my fitbit tells
me i have not gotten 250 steps for that
hour and i walk around in place like
anyone who has a fitbit definitely gets
that annoying reminder but it's so good
because you can do it frequently whereas
training you can't you can't like lift
weights every hour you can walk every
hour and that breaks up sedentary
moments throughout the day even if it's
just for one minute that you're getting
up and walking around you're getting
your muscles flexing you're getting your
muscles actually using energy which
makes the body more insulin sensitive
and helps it more easily burn fat as
fuel as a result too so just from a
purely practical perspective like you
mentioned you could walk all day or even
if you don't have the opportunity to
walk you know 14 miles through the park
on a beautiful new york day anyone can
get up from their desk and stand for one
minute and walk around their office it's
just such a practical approach to
keeping insulin sensitivity high and
getting the body moving so that you're
actually contracting your muscles um and
using fat as fuel the process if you
were to put into
words your ideal day and your ideal week
like how would that look from your
perspective
uh do you mean like just from exercise
yeah like exercise nutrition fasting you
know does and and then also do you and
then maybe especially i'm just so
curious from a female perspective
because so many somebody there's such a
lack of studies done on women
um like is there a certain time in the
month where you would be more apt to do
some more of one thing or less of
another
yeah um well just for a regular day i
mean typically i wake up the first thing
i do is i go for a walk because that
helps to get your body actually moving
obviously you get your insulin
sensitivity higher
you get to use fat to steal when your
body is most primed to be using fattest
fuel and personally just wakes me up
right away so do that completely fasted
um and then i always come back and do
strength training workout right after
that still during the completely fasted
state uh to maximize all those growth
hormone benefits um and then i
personally use keto coffee i can't do
black coffee i love keto coffee so i
stick with that route and i transition
into more of a fasting mimicking state
around like eight or nine a.m and then
totally break my fast anywhere between
10 a.m to noon really depends on if i
have clients that day or if i'm just
filming um i always break my fast with
protein fat and fiber so it's usually
going to be a smoothie that has greek
yogurt protein powder chia seeds um
peanut butter using coconut milk um a
low sugar fruit like a small amount of
berries um strawberries raspberries and
then all i typically personally use a
three meal structure i just found like
if i do two meals i'm way too hungry
like i just can't do it so i have a
three meal structure not snacking
between just having water um having sea
salt
i also use apple cider vinegar before i
break my fast to help stabilize blood
glucose levels before the first meal
um
and then my second meal usually like
scrambled eggs eggs are one of the best
protein sources it's so bio-available
it's the most bio-available protein
and also rich in fat so it's like an
easy one where you don't have to over
complicate adding in all these
ingredients
uh and then personally for myself for
dinner usually on 6 p.m and
i'm going to be i mean i have i like to
make recipes i love to cook
so it's
all across the board like beef stew
burgers something along those lines um
and take my magnesium go to bed and
repeat it the next day
and then that's there's no is there any
kind of cycling or any any difference
between
no i've not found the cycling to be
sustainable first of all because again
it goes back to each issue same thing as
adf it gets or alternate day fasting
gets so confusing for so many people and
i've not found it actually to be
beneficial um at all for all the effort
that it takes in your brain space where
we all have so much to think about
anyway like to try and overcomplicate
how we eat and when we eat and if we can
just keep it consistent get enough the
right types of foods you can solve 99 of
your problems with that alone and just
most people aren't even doing that but
over complicating if that one percent
tweak hmm
what about hacks like do you any are
there any kind of just you know i i feel
like it's such an overused word but are
there any things that you do that like
i'm just as an example like
like things that i do like cold shower
or
um you know red light or
uh
amethyst biomat or you know whatever it
may be are there any things that you
have in your regular routine that um are
cool and fun that you're testing out and
you feel like you like
um
i'm not much of like in the biohacking
area again i like to keep it simple and
realistic and so much of what
our body needs comes from the simple and
realistic things we're going to be doing
every day um with red light i'd rather
go outside and just get all of the light
from all the spectrums that i
and i have the privilege of working from
home where i can go on walks and um when
it's not freezing out like it is right
now wear a shirt that allows me to show
my arms and get full exposure and also
get vitamin d so i think that like the
the
i am interested in hearing all of the
biohacking information i think it's an
interesting world but i also think that
it's kind of overlooking the point of
the fact that kind of like supplements
like we're trying to tweak all these
little things but we don't actually know
how it's going to affect the big picture
where you can get the same things from
the whole source just by going outside
or you know cold shower is cool i
actually do like that i think that's a
great option it does help to
convert the
white fat into brown fat that's more
metabolically active i'm a wuss i don't
do that i should but i can't um but yeah
i hate the cold so much i hate the cold
so much which makes me feel like i'm
supposed to do it yeah and i have to do
sauna because like with a detoxing heavy
metals like sweating is such a such a
way to do it um yeah i mean hassan is
not as hard but i i get knocked out like
saunas make me feel pretty exhausted
actually yeah i mean probably because
you're releasing so much so that would
make sense
um but yeah i mean the the only like
hacks i might use is like using
magnesium to help improve my melatonin
um or if i'm experiencing higher than
usual amounts of anxiety then i'll use
l-theanine which is a really great amino
acid
that's taken from green tea to help with
naturally reducing stress levels so that
was like a little bit of a hack i guess
um but in terms of intermittent fasting
hack my biggest one is keto coffee like
honestly it's so great to help the gut
healing aspect and reducing hunger while
still getting the low insulin levels so
it's just i mean butter coconut oil and
coffee
it's awesome what about could i because
i'm like i'm i don't know maybe you're
similar i i don't i get hungry in the
morning like in the earlier part of the
day like i feel hungry and then as the
day goes on like take for example the
day that i was supposed to eat whatever
i wanted all day which i all i did was
eat the healthy stuff but i just got
broke out of the mold of like
the three things i could eat and so
um but it got to dinner time and i
remember i was like eating normal but i
was eating like
just stuff i wasn't but it wasn't able
to eat um like outside of the beans and
greens and stuff and i thought i'm still
kind of hungry but i'm i'm not trying to
kill it i don't need to like be stupid
and then nighttime came and i was like
having some rice and some greens and
some broccolini and chicken and and i
was eating i just i just felt stuffed i
like felt i get so full so can i
like keto coffee is always something
that you think about for the morning
right you always think about it for the
morning but can you
can you
can you consider it the start of your
fast if you did a keto coffee like a
decaf keto coffee at night
um it well it just depends on the type
of fasting you're using so if you wanted
a true fast um then it technically
breaks a fast if you're looking at
fasting mimicking like what i was
referring to um then yeah it's it would
be counted as part of your fast you
could do that but you said you got
hungry in the morning right or the
morning less at night yeah like you
would want to do it in the morning then
when you're actually hungry um so you
get the fat to actually signal the the
um closest to kinding to make sure it
shuts off your hunger hormones oh
so if you're trying to so true fasting
is not having any calories it's nothing
i mean it's even like stevia can spike
like there's it's very sensitive even
coffee can right and so you want to be
careful like when you're actually in
your fasting window to truly give your
stomach a break so when you say fast
fasting mimicking what are you trying to
accomplish by the mimicking
so it's still lower insulin and that's
one of the
main hormones that we're stimulating all
day long that's our anabolic hormone
it's our storing hormone so if we're
looking at trying to give our body a
break in terms of being in a catabolic
versus an anabolic state just by not
raising insulin you're not you know in
that um storing mode so especially from
a weight loss perspective or if you're
just new to inner fasting or if you're
hungry during the fast there's no reason
why you should have to push yourself all
the way to that point um of having a
true fast when you could have a true
fast for let's say 12 hours or 14 hours
and then that last two hours you have
your keto coffee then you're just two
hours of the fasting mimicking you still
get most of the benefits anyway but
you're not hungry because you just need
to get to that sort of 12 14 mark and
then most of the benefits of the fasting
which is kind of it sounds like if you
have dinner at six and you have your
coffee by like eight you're kind of
hitting that twelve to fourteen fourteen
hour mark and then a couple hours later
you finally eat whether it's ten or
twelve years fourteen sixteen or eight
depending on what you're doing so the
fasting mimicking is really just to kind
of tide it's it's it's just allowing you
to it just not spiking your insulin
because it's just fat because fat does
nothing to insulin fat does not spike
insulin on its own so you're kind of
staying in that state but you're but
you're not actually fasting from like
a montophagy standpoint from a cellular
standpoint because you do get yeah
right so you don't get the biggest one
that you don't get is migrating motor
complex because right when you do
consume anything that's when that turns
off so that's why i like to have
definitely a true fast buffer from the
evening and in the morning so i get the
motor complex stimulated and i like to
have zero snacks in between my meals to
get that stimulated as well um but you
still get the energy levels which is
what a lot of people love with fasting
you still get the brain the mental
clarity or the energy boost and you're
not hungry um so from those perspectives
you get all those other benefits but you
just and the fat burn state of course
which is one that a lot of people are
interested in you just aren't getting
some of the other benefits or at least
not during that last two hours which at
that point we're just we're just
nitpicking you know you're we're still
getting 14 hours of fast and if you can
double down and not have
snacks between meals you're also getting
that period of rest as well in between
because you always recommend there to be
like
four hours essentially between meals
uh yeah um definitely if you're looking
to maximize gut health but that you know
i don't want people to think that if
they're having like an eight-hour eating
window that they have like two minutes
to eat meals in between each one just
not even having snacks like that's the
goal because then you still get some
amount of stimulation between meals yeah
well i tell you what gone are the days
where i mean i used to wake up in the
morning no matter what time it was i
would eat even if i wasn't hungry in the
morning i would eat first thing in the
morning and i would ever the only thing
i would say is i did eat every sort of
three or four hours i would try and use
that as a guide because i just i was
felt like i was hungry more than that
but i was like gosh this one it's only
been two hours i really gotta hang on
here but i would eat like sit five or
five times a day you know what i think
it's kind of curiosity because you said
you it's like intermittent fasting is
difficult um for you what is it that
you're eating during your eating window
minus this time right now where i'm
eating really like simple which was like
i had two eggs couple pieces of bacon um
and i bet and i'm always buying like
whole 30 approved kind of level so
there's no sugar in the bacon like i
mean i don't eat bacon that often i
haven't had bacon for a while and it was
delicious
a couple eggs i had some sauteed spinach
um
lentils avocado quarter avocado that was
by breakfast this morning breakfast okay
yeah and then um something
normal for lunch right now would be like
arugula with olive oil a little
balsamic um chicken
um and maybe some black beans or refried
beans
um another another meal that would be um
sort of on the sweet spectrum but is
such a healthy version like i'd mash up
half of a half of a banana with uh like
protein uh i use the i like epic protein
it's a good one it's like a sacha inchi
protein and or i use a pea protein so a
plant-based one and i'll put probably
you know somewhere between around 25
grams worth of that protein in it
and um then i just thin it out with
enough like almond milk or whatever milk
i have like plant-based milk to thin it
out and then i top it with like coconut
mana have you ever had coconut mana of
course that's in so many of my smoothies
nature's frosting if anyone doesn't know
what coconut is you're missing out and
you're right it's a smoothie and it
makes it so creamy
yeah yeah and then maybe a little bit of
something like a cashew butter or
something like that
and i don't really add too much fruit to
that i don't really add fruit just like
the half a banana and there is enough
and um which is cool having the
the monitor to check my blood glucose
spike it didn't do anything so i know
that it's not something that spikes it
um and dinner like steak or
vegetables
i know sweet potatoes spike my spike my
blood sugar so i don't have sweet
potatoes so rice didn't do anything so i
can have that or like a taco night with
a corn tortilla chips like corn tortilla
stuff doesn't spike it either so i know
that doesn't
but vegetables and avocado and
maybe every now and again a smoothie
which i super low on fruit putting it in
my smoothie you need to get a lot of
calories in a smoothie
and i love chia pudding like i make
a lot of times like a breakfast instead
of oatmeal i'll have because oats were
like through the roots
blood sugar
it's terrible and i would do chia seeds
with hot water and then put some plant
protein in it and i top it again with
like a little little coconut man or
something to melt on it and it's a
really like very low sugar kind of meal
um and so that'd be another common meal
so i i feel like i eat pretty
you yeah you have a lot of great
ingredients in there yeah um so
recommendations i was just trying to
mentally calculate everything so um how
many ounces of like steak or chicken
would you say you generally have
i mean i would say that because i don't
count uh now but i have counted before
just to see
and it does take a bit of effort to get
to 100 grams i i mean i kind of use the
guideline and i don't weigh 100 pounds
but i kind of use the guideline of
trying to get to 100 grams or like i've
heard a gram per per pound of body
weight
um
and so i mean i i'd say that's probably
about what i get i eat more protein than
i used to um so uh because that was i
was kind of counting more in that time
where i was trying to be a little bit
more kind to the animals right
but i'd say i'd probably get somewhere
around
80 to 100 every day from all from
complete or including incomplete
um
mostly complete okay yeah
it would be like you're saying like if
you like let's say if you track the
whole day and yeah if there were beans
or peanut butter or something that
contributed yeah not really i'd say a
solid 80 to 90 of complete protein okay
great so then you're probably getting
mental math um like five ounces of
chicken or yeah yeah yeah i'd say i'm
i'm a little bit more generous with my
protein sources right now because i'm
eating more like that's my my main
satiation along with the fat is like
yeah greens don't go real far right do
you usually start off with some type of
starch in the morning like lentils no i
mean i do put it in my i do right now
but a lot of times a very common
breakfast that i would have before i was
trying this bean situation was i'd have
um ground bison i'd throw spinach in
there and saute it up so it's just
ground bison spinach and then i'd have a
piece of like
vegan gluten-free bread and i'd put um
avocado on it and turmeric and salt and
pepper and broccoli sprouts and
yeah
yeah um so you you always have some type
of starch then because like yeah i guess
there would be true yeah that would be
true i found that tends to spike hunger
throughout the day really yeah i would
experiment just take out the starch and
experiment with replacing that with
another fat so that you can just add in
a satiety factor and just keep a starch
in the evening so you get the perks of
um getting higher quality sleep see if
that helps if you're getting 100 grams
of protein then you're probably fine
there but see if adding in the fat
removing the starch from the morning um
helps to make it so you're just hungry
throughout the day i love that that's a
great suggestion because you're right
somehow in my mind i think i should have
a little bit of everything yeah yeah and
we usually don't eat as much of the fat
as we think we are so the fat component
especially if you consider you're
removing that other energy source which
is the carbohydrate you need another
energy source to come back in so just
make sure you're actually replacing up
the whole source like instead of that
slice have a extra half an avocado yeah
yeah because again like we learned
your sources of energy come from fat
or carbohydrate you're either
sugar burner exactly protein i mean i
guess that's so funny i never i mean all
the all the nutritional information i've
consumed i didn't even think about the
fact that like i didn't i guess i didn't
even know that yeah it's going back to
what i was saying it's because so many
people with intermittent fasting are
focused on the fast not the eating
window and so they completely forget to
really
analyze that area which is what my whole
youtube channel is based off of because
that's what i did wrong was not looking
at the eating window
wow
well thank you you've been a total
wealth of knowledge i really appreciate
it and i'm sure i'll just keep watching
your videos and then i'll just keep
having more questions so um
but i'll let you know what they are
along the way oh yeah anytime i always
love talking about nutrition obviously
it's all i think about or talk about so
i'm always here
thank you autumn thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the subscribe
button